بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اذ يوحي ربك الى
الملائكه اني معكم فثبتوا الذين امنوا
سالقي في قلوب الذين كفروا الرعب فاضربوا
فوق الاعناق واضربوا منهم كل
بنان الحمد لله الذي كتب العزه والغلبه
للمؤمنين والذله والخزي على المعتدين
والصلاه والسلام على نبينا المجاهد الشهيد
وعلى اله وصحبه ومن جاهد جهاده
وبعد يا ابناء شعبنا المجاهد البطل
العظيم يا مجاهدين المغاوير ومقاتلي شعبنا
وامتنا يا جماهير امتنا ويا كل احرار
العالم السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته 76 يوما مرت على بدء معركه طوفان
الاقصى وعلى العدوان الهمجي الصهيوني على
شعبنا في قطاع
غزه ولا يزال العدو يمارس جرائم الحرب
المسجله باسمه في تاريخ الجرائم ضد
الانسانيه ولا يزال مجاهدون في الميدان
يتصدون
للعدوان ويقاتلون العدو المجرم المرتعد
ويكبد وه خسائر فادحه في جنوده وضباطه
واليات
ويشل
كيانه رغم امتلاكه لترسانه ضخمه ورغم
تلقيه دعما عسكريا
هائلا لا يدل في حقيقه الامر الا على ضعف
هذا الكيان المتعلق بتحالفات ظالمه باغيه
ستنقطع حبالها عنه طال الزمان ام
قصر ان مجاهدين على الارض يستمر في تدمير
اليات العدو
واستهدافها بكافه انواع الاسلحه المتاحه
وايقاع جنوده في شراك وكمائن
قاتله وملاحقتهم خارج اليات وفي المباني
التي يتحصنون فيها في مناطق التجمع موقعين
العشرات من جنود العدو قتلا والمئات جرحى
ومصابين في خسائر متصاعده لا تكاد تتوقف
على مدار الساعه وستزيد باذن الله طالما
استمر
العدوان وقد بلغت حصيله الاليات التي
دمرها مجاهدو خلال الاسبوع
الاخير عشرات
الاليات كنا قد اعلنا عنها
تباعا فيما بلغ عدد الاليات
العسكريه التي استهدفنا منذ بدء العدوان
البري
720 اليه بين ناقلات ج ودبابات وجرافات
ومركبات وشاحنات
عسكريه وتنوعت نتائج هذه
الاستهدافات بين التدمير الكلي او الاعطاب
الجزئي وتوزعت هذه الاستهدافات بين كافه
محاور التوغل الصهيوني من بيت حانون شمالا
الى خانيونس جنوبا وعلى مدار ايام
العدوان كما نفذ مجاهدو بفضل الله تعالى
خلال الاسبوع الاخير اكثر من 15 عمليه قنص
ناجحه واكثر من 2 اشتباكا مباشرا بالاسلحه
الرشاشه والمتوسطه والقنابل اليدويه
واستخدم مجاهدو في عمليات الالتحام على
نطاق واسع وفي كل المحاور العبوات الناسفه
المضاده للافراد وعبوات العمل الفدائي
والعبوات المضاده للدروع بكافه انواعه
والقذائف المضاده للتحصينات والافراد
والاليات يا ابناء شعبنا وامتنا ويا كل
احرار
العالم اننا في كتائب القسام وبعد احد عشر
اسبوعا من التصدي للعدوان والحرب الهمجيه
النازيه نؤكد على ما
يلي اولا ان ما ينشغل به جيش العدو اليوم
على الارض هو البحث عن صوره للنصر
والانجاز فتاره يعلن عن اغتيال قيادات
ميدانيه واستهداف مجاهدين على الارض وتاره
يحتفل باكتشاف نفق قديم خارج عن الخدمه او
قصف راجمه صواريخ تم استعمالها وانتهت
صلاحيتها وتاره يحتفي باستيلائه على مواقع
عسكريه او مكاتب ومساكن مخلاه قصفها
باطنان المتفجرات
مسبقا وتاره يستعرض بالتدمير والقتل لل
العشوائي كرده فعل على فشله وخسائره
الكبيره وهذا العدو التائه المازو
المتغطرس لم يتعلم من تجارب التاريخ ولو
درسا
واحدا فقد سبق واغتال القاده وقتل
المجاهدين من ابناء شعبنا بالالاف فانبتت
دماؤهم نصرا واورثت ارواحهم مقاومتنا قوه
وعنفوان وقد سبق ان دمر العدو وافسد وقت
وهجر وارتكب المجازر عبر تاريخه الاسود
الدموي فلم يترك لشعبنا خيارا سوى
الانتقام منه وتدفي ثمن جرائمه ومجازره
والاصرار على مقاومته والعمل على كنسه ولا
يزال يكرر حماقاته واخطائه
التاريخيه لانه كغيره من الغزاه
المحتلين منفصل عن واقع شعبنا وجاهل
بثقافته
وحضارته ولا يدرك معنى اراده الشعوب الحره
التي تسعى للانعتاق من
الاحتلال ثانيا ان هدف العدو القضاء على
المقاومه هو امر محكوم عليه بالفشل وقد
باتت هذه حقيقه لا جدال
فيها اما هدف استعاده اسراه فقد اثبتت
عمليات العدو الفاشله والمرتبه ما اعلنا
منذ اليوم الاول للحرب بان مسار هذه
القضيه هو التبا
فاستمرار العدوان لا يسمح اصلا باطلاق
سراح الاسرى مطلقا فضلا عن امكانيه
تحريرهم بالعمليات العسكريه
المباشره لذلك اذا اراد العدو
وجمهوره اسراهم احياء فليس امامهم سوى وقف
العدوان والدخول في التفاوض بمسارات
المعروفه عبر
الوسطاء وهذا موقف ثابت ولا بديل عنه سوى
استمرار تساقط اسرى عدو قتلى بنيران جيشهم
المتغطرس وبقرار من قيادتهم السياسيه التي
تهرب من مواجهه الحقيقه والاعتراف
بها ثالثا نوجه التحيه لشعبنا في الضفه
والقدس المحتله الذين يتعرضون لهجمه نازيه
تدل على كذب العدو واجرامه وامع انه في
الطغيان سواء قاتل شعبنا وامتلك السلاح
والعتاد او كان اعزل يقاتل ببضعه بنادق
وحجاره وخناجر
فخذوا يا ابناء شعبنا الكتاب بقوه واشحذ
اسلحتكم للدفاع عن كرامتكم ومقدسات وراكم
وبيوتكم
واعراضكم كما نحيي مقاتلي امتنا الذين
يربكون العدو ومن وراءه في دك لجبهات
عسكريا واقتصاديا ومعنويا وامنيا خاصه في
جبهتي اليمن ولبنان مما جعل الاحتلال
يستنجد بارباب طلبا للحمايه وخوفا من
القادم الادهى والامر بقوه الله
وامره
وختاما نشد على ايادي ابناء شعبنا العظيم
الصابر الذي يحمل اثقالا كالجبال في
مواجهه هذه المحرقه النازيه
الصهيونيه لكنه يقف شامخا صابرا على ارضه
والتحيه لكل مجاهدينا ومقاوم شعبنا في
الميدان الذين اذهلوا العدو والصديق
بصمودهم وباس وصلابته
وبطولاتهم واننا على يقين بالله بان هذا
الصبر والصمود الملحمي لن يضيع في ميزان
الله وستكون عاقبته خير وفتح وكرامه
وسيكون مقدمه لنصر عظيم بعون الله وقوته
والله غالب على امره ولكن اكثر الناس لا
يعلمون وانه لجهاد نصر او استشهاد والسلام
عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته